sebastian baut heute die praktische fünf
minuten terrine nach für so eine
fertigsuppe brauchte er einige tricks
der lebensmittelindustrie damit sie auch
wirklich jahre lang haltbar bleibt schon
verblüffend einfach nur wasser drauf wo
fertig es im gericht und alles ohne
kühlung ja das steht ja einfach nur so
im regal
ich zeige ihnen gleich mal wie es
funktioniert sebastian lege demonstriert
uns das prinzip der tütensuppe am anfang
steht auch hier das schnitzel unserer
peter sie brauchen dich die blätter die
stängel sind das interessante erstmal
super günstig in zwei ideale sellerie
ersatz clevere resteverwertung muss ja
nichts schlechtes sein
alle zutaten kochen und würzen fertig
ist der baukasten für einen klassischen
hühner nudeltopf
[Musik]
sind sie schon mal ganz so gut aus
kunterbunt mit nudeln hühnerfleisch
märchen
feuchtigkeit ist der nährboden für
schimmel und andere mikroorganismen soll
ein lebensmittel haltbar sein darf es
nur wenig wasser enthalten
das dörren von obst fleisch und gemüse
ist eine der ältesten
konservierungsmethode überhaupt
und die modernste ist das gefriert
trocknen
da wird selbst kaffee zum praktischen
instant getränke auch sebastian lege
setzt aufs gefrier trockenen für seine
hühner tütensuppe
das ganze gehen wir jetzt einen job
frosta weil die schockfrosten entstehen
kopisch kleine eiskristalle nicht wie
beim normalen frosta wo relativ großer
eiskristalle entstehen was alles
matschig machen würde je kleiner die
eiskristalle desto weniger zellen und
gewebe gehen kaputt
deshalb kommen auch tiefkühlgerichte
stets schockgefrostet in die tüte in
dieser apparatur soll nun das
eigentliche trockenen stattfinden ohne
vorheriges auftauen normales trockenen
kennt jeder man links draußen in der
sonne
man wartet bis das wasser verschwunden
ist und es ist trocken
hier wollen wir aber das aus eis nicht
wasser sondern gas wird es das nicht
schmilzt sondern verdampft das gibt es
wirklich aber nur im vakuum
man setzt die gefrorenen suppen zutaten
also extrem niedrigen luftdruck aus dann
können die eiskristalle langsam aber
sicher verdampfen
dabei hinterlassen sie millionen winzige
hohlräume und die saugen sich später
beim aufgießen mit kochendem wasser
wieder voll
[Musik]
jetzt muss läge die trocknungs apparatur
ordentlich kühlen
denn die suppen zutaten sollen ja nicht
aufbauen bevor die eiskristalle im
inneren restlos verdampft sind nur wenn
wirklich vakuum herrscht klappt der
dreck der schlauch ist dran und unserer
unter druckpumpe hier rechts ist unser
nudelgericht ich hoffe mal wir erzeugen
ein ähnliches ergebnis wie die industrie
jetzt zumindest mal 24 stunden warten
und dann heißt es ab dem becher und
heißwasser drauf ob der
produktentwickler mit seinem
selbstgebauten apparat 1 endstand
gericht zu stande bringt und schadet
gefriertrocknung eigentlich den
vitaminen etwa bei erbsen es gibt sie
frisch oder tiefgekühlt
gefriergetrocknet in instant gerichten
oder eingekocht in der dose welche haben
wohl am meisten vitamin c pro 100 gramm
kurios weil bis zum verkauf schon zeit
vergeht haben frische erbsen weniger
vitamine als tiefkühl erzen die gleich
nach der ernte eingefroren werden die
dosen erbsen mit 5,6 milligramm klarer
verlierer dagegen punkten die
gefriergetrockneten erbsen mit über 13
milligramm
nachdem aufgießen mit wasser sind sie
fast genauso gut wie frisch geerntet
läge selbst gebauter gefriertrocknung
ist 24 stunden gelaufen und hat sich das
nudelgericht in ein staubtrockene
produkt verwandelt dass man in die tüte
bröseln und verkaufen könnte durchaus
aber klappt auch das aufbrühen der
endstand suppe
essen ist fertig
siehe da das gefriert trocknen im
eigenbau hat funktioniert und wie
schmeckt
[Musik]
na ja gar nicht so schlecht
wie man sehen kann die erbs ist richtig
frei geworden die möhre hat auch wieder
zu ihrem ursprung gefunden
super lieben frisches nudelgericht und
wie schneidet im vergleich die gekaufte
tütensuppe
[Musik]
die war sie wenn das huhn sein soll
wonach das schmeckt nach vielen
natürlichen geschmack
[Musik]
eigentlich schade denn das experiment
hat gezeigt entstand produkte müssen
nicht automatisch schlecht sein
gefriertrocknung ist ein cleveres
verfahren
die industrie kann damit haltbare leicht
zu transportierende produkte anbieten
mit guten nährwerten und einfache
zubereitung
[Musik]
auch pfannkuchen geht's heute schon als
kunstprodukt einfallsreiche firmen
bringen gerne mal klassische
lieblingsgerichte als fertig mix auf den
markt und werben damit dass die
zubereitung besonders schnell geht und
garantiert gelingt aber wie viel zeit
spart man mit so einem instant
pfannkuchen wirklich eine erfahrene
hausfrau und ein student werden dass wir
uns ausprobieren
irene richard wird ihre pfannkuchen aus
frischen zutaten herstellen
makkabis macht sich leicht und greift
zur flasche viel schiefgehen kann beim
instant an kuchen eigentlich nicht alle
zutaten bis auf milch sind bereits fix
und fertig vor gemischt in der flasche
beim pfannkuchen backen auf zeit müsste
unser student damit einen entscheidenden
vorteil haben
die stoppuhr läuft das endprodukt spart
jede menge handgriffe einfach 200
milliliter milch dazugeben kräftig
schütteln und fertig
das sieht doch gut aus
jetzt muss ich nur noch drei minuten
stehen lassen
student mark hat damit erst mal pause
obwohl es hier um tempo geht macht
traurig hat bei der zubereitung keine
kompromisse
ganze vier eier kommen in den teig das
eiweiß wird natürlich aufgeschlagen und
mineralwasser damit alles schön fluffig
wird so viel liebe zum detail kostet
zeit
der instant pfannkuchen landet deshalb
als erster in der pfanne
doch der zeitvorsprung ist kleiner als
gedacht
[Musik]
nummer 1 ist hätte
12 minuten und 31 sekunden für den
ersten band fun kuchen
aber das selbermachen hat kaum länger
gedauert 13 minuten und neun sekunden
dann liegt auch der traditionell
hergestellte pfannkuchen auf dem teller
und wie schmeckt
wein schmeckt hier ja jetzt wo wirst 1 x
naja also bin ich ja subjektiv
eingestellt und sagt man schmeckt etwas
besser und man merkt da keinen großen
werks einen großen unterschied
aber du hast schon recht zeitlich hätte
ich doch für das ist ein großer
unterschied ist der mehrpreis für die
minimale zeitersparnis ist jedoch
beachtlich alles in allem kosten 5
selbstgemachte pfannkuchen 72 cent
die instant variante einschließlich
milch stolze 2 euro 15
schnell und billig durch fertig max das
haut hier beides nicht hin
[Musik]
fazit instanz produkte müssen nicht
schlecht sein
nur halten nicht alle was sie
versprechen und wer es kinderleicht will
der zahlt drauf
greift ihr auch manchmal zu instant
produkten sagt es uns in den kommentaren
und wenn ihr noch mehr über euer essen
wissen wollt dann abonnier zdf besser
esser und schaut für die nächsten zwei
clips
[Musik]